do you think doing all the work that
you've done in the last few years that
you know going back in time you would
have crashed me as many times as you did
be honest with you I did not Crush you
at all since stop it things happen but
yeah
three times in a week I know I know I
was a little aggressive for sure
um but you know usually when I crash my
friends it's only because I'm trying to
help but uh yeah I'm glad you just
dumped my primary car my back up and
then had to go to another backup for the
Daytona 500. that was what I was
planning too trust me the second one I
think it was during the duel when you
crash I I hadn't even thought about the
fact that like well she's got a race for
like she's not locked in she has to get
in and so I'm like oh no I'm just
praying the whole time that race is
going on I totally put out of my mind
what my result was going to be that day
I'm like please let her make the race
please let her make the race because you
crashed me yes thanks I did I know I
know uh and so yeah that was a relief
but I knew as soon as I got out of the
car uh I turned around I was like I saw
you stomping down pit Lane and I'm like
well you gotta just take it and so for
me it's it's it is different because
unlike you know if it was a guy and he
grabbed me by I was like you know I'm
like hey let's talk you know but for you
I'm like I got you sit here and take it
sit here and take it
yeah if she kicks you in the balls take
it I I gotta just take this in stride
and so uh there was just there was no
way for me to win in in the public
perception when you were coming up to me
I'm like yeah I can't turn her away I
can't argue back with her I just I gotta
be a man here and just take it like a
man
were you scared at all
um yes and no because I I just I knew
that we had had a relationship you know
as friends for a while leading up to
that so I I knew that like you're
yelling at me because you care and
you're yelling at me because you're
comfortable enough around me to voice
your opinion and you know me enough that
I will take it and hear it
so looking back at the scenario you
think I think you told me like you're
too loose I I didn't do anything wrong
you're just too loose let's just be
really honest like tell me like the
serious what really was going on in your
head like is that a fact or was it
something else well I I do think your
cars were too loose yes I I it's so
interesting when I watch some of these
cars like Hendrick cars and stuff and
like how loose they run their cars
during you know speedway races and I'm
like gosh I can't even get the whole way
I'm gonna make you go faster is me
pushing you and if I can't push you then
like you know you're not I'm not gonna
help you I'm just gonna try to dump you
every chance that I get
um I always try to push people that I
feel like are very stable their cars
were stable and I can hit them without
them spinning out but there's just a
group of cars and it was you know I
think at the time y'all might have had a
Hendrick Alliance I'm not really sure
but
um yeah it's just they always run their
car so loose that it just it's really
hard to work with them and so uh you
know even to this day it's it's kind of
the same old thing but you know I I
wanted to help but honestly you know it
was just a mistake that that I made and
I've made so many in the course of my
career
um you know making aggressive moves to
you know I've always learned and if you
ever hear Dale Jr say
um you know the way he's found success
on super Speedways is being selfish and
and yeah I'm not the greatest teammate
on on super speedway races I found
success by doing for myself
um and so the the this year's Daytona
500 I committed to pushing my teammates
so I'm thinking in my head I shouldn't
be here this is a spot I don't want to
be in I see cars starting to get riled
up and a wreck is coming and I'm like I
should just bail but I told these guys I
would stick with them and I didn't bail
bam I got crashed and so I just feel
like that type of racing you have to be
a little bit selfish but you have to
make aggressive moves and so sometimes
that comes at other people's expense
yeah I'm thank I'm glad thank you for
confessing that you dumped me I I did I
did yeah you know what I look at it like
is that you as a driver we as drivers
whatever
we know when we leave no room for air
because we just don't give a [ __ ]
and you don't really care if you hit
someone and that to me feels like a lot
of times the scenario people put
themselves is and is they're just like
I'm leaving I don't care I really don't
care
you know I tried to be I feel like on
the spectrum of super aggressive and
super passive I honestly feel like I'm
on the passive side of my aggression
level I mean my team tells me all the
time like you got to hit that hole you
gotta you gotta you gotta be more
aggressive like we feel like we could
win more races if you're more aggressive
and I'm like I get it but you know to me
there's no art to passing by just
knocking someone out of the way like
that's not I was raised by watching some
of the greatest short track racers like
work over someone and and save their
tires and then blow past them in the
long run and pass them and I was like
that's how I emulated my style and now
of course I've made mistakes along the
way I've wrecked people for sure none
have been intentional except for
sort of one not you no no it's Chase
Elliott 2017 Martinsville no intentions
of wrecking him I was just trying to
knock him out of the way but he's fun
and then you know it tainted my you know
Legacy with the Chase Elliott crowd from
this point on they just can't they can't
get rid of they can't get over it but
it's like you know we all make mistakes
because we're in a business where we run
right up next to each other and we have
to manipulate sometimes that other
person's car to get speed out of ours
and so I feel like I'm I'm kind of on
the passive side but there's always been
I've been doing this for 18 years so if
I have a handful of moments where I've
really crashed someone you know that's
that's not bad
don't be better it's okay
do you think NASCAR should not intervene
with retaliations and crashing because
it always feels like NASCAR gets after
the retaliation and not the initial they
they set a press events when Matt
Kenseth wrecked Joey Logano oh yeah that
was so exciting though it was so
exciting
we heard the crowd right I mean we heard
the crowd going nuts when it happened
for those who don't know he was uh Matt
Kenseth was taken out by Joey Logano and
he needed to get through to the chase by
winning and he was in the lead he took
him out and then the next weekend at
Martinsville nothing happened while he
was up there up in the mix for top three
top five but then once he was a lap down
he waited and came back up on track and
when the green flag dropped at the end
of the race he just freaking dumped Joey
and I for one am joyful about that
because Joey's a jackass on the track he
also is another one that I don't like
probably more than you even
um but he crashed me too and he he's
just a little punk out there look at
just look at his track record just look
at how many people have a beef with him
yeah it's tough because Joey's you know
on that Spectrum I'm talking about he's
all the way on the full end right you
know he is very aggressive and it's been
successful for him but ultimately I mean
sometimes you care about friends
sometimes you don't and and you know
it's not just that but I feel like at
that time yeah Kansas had had enough and
oh yeah I'm just I'm destroying you I'm
making sure you don't make another
corner and NASCAR suspended Matt over
that and their reasoning was is that we
never have stepped in like this before
but Matt wasn't on the lead lap he
slowed down and waited for Joey to come
by and he's just deliberately smashed
him so they said you know it's fair game
as long as you're racing poor position
so we're racing up front
um it's kind of fair game and we saw it
with Ross Chastain and myself earlier
this year I mean we're racing one two
yeah I mean he he's crashed me multiple
times this year and I've always said you
know it will come back around in due
time and and you know I had one
opportunity so far that uh you know lent
itself to me we were battling for the
race win at Pocono and I just left him
zero room and and essentially let him
wreck himself in that scenario and you
know if I'm him I know that okay I've
done this guy wrong he's probably gonna
force me high I probably should check up
he didn't check up and just ran himself
right into the fence but
um it was just NASCAR was okay with that
because we're Racing for a position now
if I had slowed down and just took him
out I think that they have an exception
for that but the problem they need to
let it go and let us continue to police
it because otherwise you know it's just
going to be a bunch of penalties and
that's not gonna be fun for anyone well
the problem I have is that if you're
Racing for position
then you have something on the line and
so it doesn't seem fair like you know if
they took you out you might probably
might not be on the lead lap anymore if
something happened so then they get to
be up there but then you have to wait
until you have something on the line
again yeah and that's [ __ ] I think
you should get the chance I think that
you should just if it all self-policed
itself out there it would all be taken
care of and it would get back to like
rough and rowdy like you know NASCAR
just like Let It Rip I think I love
fights though like I was just so excited
when one was happening and I could hear
one or a red flag would come out and I
heard the crowd I'm like on the radio
I'm like gosh I know there's a fight
what's going on
yeah it's it's different I mean I tried
to a little bit when he wrecked me the
first time at Gateway it you probably
saw highlights of me running around 30
miles an hour swerving back and forth
like slowing him down like he almost got
disqualified from the race for not
making minimum speed I was one lap away
from keeping them from running minimum
speed which would have got him dequeued
and I I knew that I couldn't being a
lockdown at my car was beat up I knew
that I couldn't make contact with him
but I I didn't want him to know that so
I just every time he was around me I
would take a swipe here and there uh
just to voice my anger because I knew
that we weren't going to talk afterwards
and
um it was just uh you know he he
understands where I stand in it
um we've we've raced each other pretty
well since those couple events instances
but
um you know you still you drivers always
keep a scorecard in the back of their
head
foreign